starting pitching for the tigers is
matthew boyd matthews numbers let's just
throw those out we don't want to look at
those what we want is a guy to come out
and attack the strike zone he's got his
hands full against the lead off man
because the leadoff man has owned him
yes he has whitmerfield whit has turned
around that slump he was in
as we figured he would and that's a good
looking swing there deep into right
center field and that's off the wall
played by cameron and whit begins the
road trip with a double
now the one-two
off the end of the bat to second nico
goodrum
passes his first test and matthew boyd
avoids some damage jacob junas fills in
for danny duffy in detroit tonight and
they'll be facing jacob junis
for the first time this year they saw
junius four times last year jamer
candelario last week over 400 to an al
player of the week honors
the 1-1 on the ground charged by lopez
he'll get the force on cabrera at second
there's two away and the tigers have
runners at the corners swing of nico
one two driven to left that's gonna
score a run
candelario on second he'll hustle the
third that allows goodroom to cruise
into second
nico goodra welcome back one nothing
tigers
and up comes bonifacio and he's been on
a tear and it continues beautiful a
bullet to center one run is home good
runs cook it home he's there and
bonifacio will take second base
aggressive base running clutch hitting
tigers lead at 3-0
and tunis ends the inning with a
strikeout but the tigers come up with
three and two out runs to take the lead
3-2 to gutierrez
swing and a miss matthew boyd's first
strikeout comes in the second inning
crowd number two
boyd's got him o2
swung on and missed
back to back big outs from matthew boyd
here in the third
another 3-2 reaches out softly to center
but reyes is right there beautiful good
job by matthew boyd it was 3-0 to franco
and he battled back and got him to give
it a three-nothing tigers lead
and junis strikes him out and that's
jake's second miguel cabrero walked back
in the first
sends one to deep right back goes
merrifield still looking and that ball's
gone a solo blast for miguel cabrera and
the tigers have increased their lead to
four-nothing now here's jamer candelario
candelario right back up the middle they
had him shifted to pull and he beat him
the 1-1 off his glove
and everybody's safe that's going to be
it for him because zachary's got the
magic wand going against this guy
tonight well jake newberry comes out of
the bullpen because jacob junius had
such a rough outing today
deals with austin romine one two fly
ball to center bubba starling drifting
over
mario is tagging
he will come
third strikeout of the night good way to
start the fourth from matthew boyd
the 2-2 to gutierrez and he struck him
out
a couple of strikeouts from matthew boyd
in the inning second time that he
retires kansas city one two three
so in fifth inning here he's got him all
to work in and he strikes out bubba
starling to start the fifth
on the ground and a high hopper for
willy castro nice job by matthew boyd
huh another one two three
oh
and it pays off for candelario
tenth pitch of the bat is single to
right what a great at that detroit has
the first two runners aboard here in the
fifth bases are loaded with nobody out
and a fastball got him looking
oh there you go
[Applause]
and another strikeout
so the ability that zubra has to do what
he's done to the last two hitters is one
of the reasons the royals like him so
well
well that's pretty impressive
zuber
walks to and gives up a single to load
the bases with nobody out and then he
strikes out the next three
and inside for a walk so with two down
and nobody on franco and dozier are on
ron gardner is already signaled he wants
jose cisnero here to get out of the
sixth kansas city trying to stage a
two-out rally
2-1 on the ground
cut off by paredes they'll take the
force out at second
and cisnero helps matthew boyd get
through the six we'll see if willie
castro can snap this string it's five in
a row retired on strikes in the last
seven outs have been strikeouts
he's working on getting better at his
craft sends one to
left field and that ball is gone
and it's gone
a solo homer for willie castro
six nothing detroit
i guess the work in the cage is paying
off too huh
second homer for the tigers tonight
[Applause]
and now a line drive and
that'll be into left field for his
second hit
nikki lopez will go first to third turn
that fastball in you can't sneak it by
and win
cisneros strikes out the side here in
the seventh and strands two more
nice to get a win
broken back grounder to good room
first shutout of the year for the tigers
they knock off the royals six nothing
some strong power
and strong pitching